[Music]
in an open letter to the UN billionaire
Elon Musk along with 116 experts urges
banning of lethal autonomous weapons in
short killer robots like this
not really that's not what I meant I'm
referring to autonomous drones planes
and guns must think such devices will
create more devastation or be hacked for
evil ends maybe so but maybe not first
who would a technology ban actually help
those who don't have that technology
like terrorists fact is terrorists would
love a ban because it preserves the
advantages of their low-tech suicide
attacks and IEDs
but our BOTS could take them out without
risk to our men and women why in hell
would we ban that even if we had a ban
would rogue nations Obed remember we
once outlawed chemical weapons how that
work a pope actually once tried to ban a
crossbow the League of Nations tried to
ban war in 1928 it's a fact those who
make the stuff first they dictate the
rules not some governing body who hates
us anyway America innovates it's what we
do why limit that in war especially now
being more efficiently deadly is not a
bad thing hardly the more efficient a
weapon is the more you can end conflict
faster by targeting the higher-ups
precision precision killing has the
potential to end mass death my
suggestion
don't listen to musk on this one he's a
smart guy but for futurist he's living
in the past as if Islamic terror never
happened when it comes to killer robots
let's get there first and then we'll
talk um
Keiji yeah you're a fan of killer robots
oh I am like this must have a point
though does he have a point that it
could be like you could hack into it it
could be the death of us all yeah just
us Arnold Schwarzenegger I mean I'm
dominating but this stuff is I hear you
but it's already here Yeah right so we
know this already because you remember
the Dallas case where the police
officers right they brought in to that's
true all the bad guys and I worked out
really well and everyone was like yay we
love the rope you know the whole deal so
I think you can't avoid this technology
and we know other countries already
doing even the United States is
currently ahead in terms of this AI and
this technology about Israeli military
is buying by copter drones that have
machine guns attached to them to go in
so and also you know in the military
they have like these robots to go in to
you know detonate bombs and things like
that so there's a tremendous use that
can be made here like you said against
terrorists well to limit human
casualties so for that I'm for the
technology what the wars are gonna get
smaller they're gonna be more precise
that it must worry is that means it will
have more war because they'll be easier
to wage that's exactly the point that if
there's less cost like you know people
argue we don't have a draft anymore so
right if our kids if it's not your kids
that are going to fight and say oh yeah
go ahead go ahead because somebody else
do it now let's take it to another level
now you say nobody goes over we're just
deciding we're going to go attack them
with our artificial robots or whatever
and so all of a sudden more people are
getting killed now or less well they
were not getting help saying that how
every morning are getting killed yeah
more people getting killed and
potentially more innocents but I think
that what he is pointing out and I think
this is why you have a lot of people in
the in that business that you know in
high-tech saying hey hold on is that
there are legal moral questions and you
have potential for things throwing up
like someone hacking in or bad data
going in and then you have terrible
accidents if you say well how do you do
it so I'm very sensitive to what you
were saying because I was reading just
this week a story about how like some
bad guys were shooting it at Americans
or our allies and then we were able to
target that specific apartment building
and get the sniper right just terrific
right if the problem is what if the bad
guys get this yeah that's yeah I mean
you can use that argument Dana on
everything like what are the bad guy
gets it they put him they might they
might get it but let's get it first we
have to stay ahead of them yeah that's
why we have to have more imagination
it's also why I think that we should
have a different course on immigration I
think that we should have more
immigration and for h-1b visas attract
all the smart scientists that we can
make them want to live in America
utilize all of their smart here so that
they're not going somewhere else because
China wants to hire all of the rights
would be better if they were here and
then to the point that you can't these
debates already be happening remember a
couple weeks ago there was a headlines
about designer babies yeah gene editing
and however we're like oh that's not a
good idea we should
is actually already happening yeah in
other places it doesn't mean that it's
right to do it
but the technology is going to be there
so I think that if America wants to win
we have to actually have more of it here
and own it Jessi thoughts I was a donor
designer baby tell I think it's funny
how the only robots the humans want to
create our killer robots and sex robot
it's like we either want to murder
people or make love to them like where
humans are so sick but we're so
brilliant I also like musk is
self-serving like he just wants to be
like the last human the robots turn on
and he'll and okay so I'm Pro killer
robot and if there's a threat they turn
their guns on us fine there's an off
switch and a God has an off switch
give him a remote control it's the only
button that works anyway we're fine
that's another ki and then they can
override it and watch enough Jack Bauer
24 did yeah I missed that one yes